[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et à toutes
ce soir je veux pas vous parler de
relocal malheureusement
ni d'entrepreneuriat alors je vais
aborder en fait un thème qui me tient
vraiment vraiment à coeur et pour parler
de cela je vais vous raconter une toute
petite histoire j'espère que vous aimez
les histoires
alors c'est l'histoire d'une petite
fille qui était
âgée de quatre ans
alors cette petite fille là elle avait
l'habitude de vivre dans une famille
comme on appelle famille nombreuse en
fait en Afrique ou bien la grande
famille
mais qui malheureusement en fait a été
victime de violences sexuelles
et à partir de là en fait
toute sa vie car moi a changé
si vous avez en fait des amis des frères
et sœurs qui ont déjà été victimes de
violences sexuelles alors vous savez un
peu ce que ça fait en fait
désolé et pour ceux qui s'attendaient à
ce que je parle de business ce soir mais
on va briser les côtes et on va
[Musique]
les vœux en fait tout ce qui est tabou
alors cette petite fille je vais la
nommer en fait Eva
voilà l'histoire des vents en fait
qui a subi en fait un traumatisme et
vous savez les traumatismes en fait peut
être d'ordre physique
dû à cette blessure on fait ça peut être
une blessure physique en fait ou une
blessure en fait psychologique
alors
il va se retrouver en fait tout remonter
elle se retrouve renfermée sur elle-même
elle n'ose même plus sortir elle est
toujours enfermée dans sa chambre et ça
en fait il y a une aura que souvent nos
parents l'habitude de commettre il pense
que lorsque les enfants sont calmes à la
maison en fait c'est parce qu'ils sont
super intelligents
mais
après en fait ce moment que nous allons
passer ensemble vous saurez qu'il faut
faire souvent attention en fait aux
enfants qui sont calmes parce que ils
vivent souvent des situations dont il ne
peuvent pas parler en fait pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont peur est-ce que
quelqu'un a déjà eu peur en fait dans sa
vie je suppose que oui tout le monde a
déjà ressenti en fait ce que c'est que
la peur
mais l'histoire des va ne se sépare ne
s'est pas arrêté là en fait
parce qu'à un moment donné la personne
en fait qui a abusé d'elle en fait c'est
son oncle c'est-à-dire le frère à sa
mère mais la petite adieu se taire en
fait sur toute cette histoire
de peur en fait vous savez il y a
toujours les menaces si tu dis à ton
papa ou bien ta maman je vais faire si
je vais faire cela je vais faire cela et
la petite en fait c'est tu
il y a eu un changement de cadre il y a
eu un changement de maison elle se
retrouve encore dans une nouvelle cité
et là chaque fois que sa mère l'envoyait
en fait acheter quelque chose à la
boutique le boutiqueur du quartier aussi
faisait des attouchements sur elle
ça fait un deuxième cas
la même petite encore
se rend encore victime encore d'un autre
attouchement mais cette fois-ci par son
demi-frère
de vous à moi qui peut supporter ce
genre de choses pour un enfant et tout
cette situation en fait se passe entre 4
et 10 ans 7 ans
c'est quand même trop pour une petite
fille
en fait cette petite fille dont je vous
parle c'est mon histoire à moi parce que
c'est ce que j'ai vécu en fait dans mon
enfance
quelqu'un a dit waouh dans la salle
c'est vrai que je n'en parle pas souvent
mais c'est mon histoire à moi je suis
resté longtemps renfermé sur moi-même à
cause de tout ce que j'ai pu vivre en
fait dans mon enfance je parlais pas
pour les parents c'était normal elle est
super intelligente tant qu'elle envoie
des résultats ça va tout se passe bien
et la question que généralement les gens
se posent c'est de savoir mais pourquoi
est-ce que tu n'en n'as pas parlé en
fait à tes parents mon père c'était un
homme d'affaires il n'est jamais là il
rentre le soir et quand il rentre en
fait la dernière chose qu'il a envie de
voir ce sont des enfants qui devaient
tourner autour de lui il demande à ce
que nous soyons tous devant nos cahiers
et tout donc chacun se cherche
automatiquement ma mère en fait c'était
une connaissance
une femme d'affaires aussi et elle elle
n'avait vraiment pas le temps elle
devait gérer les autres enfants elle
devait gérer tout donc étant donné que
moi j'étais celle qui ne parlait pas
donc tout allait bien en fait
mais vous savez
lorsque vous avez été blessé
heureusement j'ai pas eu vraiment de
déchirure mais en fait cette blessure
pour moi elle était morale en fait
parce que c'était un état d'esprit et je
suis arrivé à un moment donné où je me
disais je veux même pas voir quelqu'un
autour de moi et j'avais même peur que
les gens s'approchent de moi parce que
chaque fois que je voyais un homme
s'approche de moi j'avais déjà peur en
fait je m'imaginais en fait qu'il allait
me faire quelque chose et ça j'ai vécu
en fait dans cette crainte là pendant
plusieurs années
jusqu'à arriver à un certain moment où
je me demandais qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
faire
est-ce que
je devais carrément c'est à dire je me
retrouve en fait à un carrefour où il y
avait un plan A ou bien disons un chemin
à et un chemin B le premier chemin en
fait c'était le chemin de la résignation
c'est à dire est-ce que
pour ceux qui ne savent pas qu'est-ce
que c'est la queue la résignation en
fait c'est juste le fait de pouvoir
accepter passivement une situation
difficile sans chercher en fait à
changer cette situation là et cela peut
conduire en fait un sentiment de de
d'impuissance ou d'abandon ou bien je
décide d'emprunter un chemin B qui a le
chemin en fait de la résilience
et la résilience
c'est juste cette capacité de pouvoir
faire face en fait au défi de se rebâtir
et de rebondir chaque fois qu'il y a des
épreuves en fait c'est cette capacité de
pouvoir trouver cette force intérieure
qui nous aide à surmonter en fait toutes
les épreuves ou les défis de la vie
pour ceux qui me connaissent je sais pas
s'il y a quelqu'un de plus résiliente
que moi en vert dans cette vie là parce
que j'ai traversé beaucoup beaucoup de
choses
et avant de continuer en fait sur mes
propos
l'année dernière en 2022 vous savez je
suis aussi Mandela à venir il fait
partie du des alumini en fait du
programme Mandela Washington fait le
ship
mais
avant d'arriver aux États-Unis ça a été
quelque chose de
waouh je sais pas si quelqu'un peut
vivre ça en fait parce que déjà nous
nous retrouvons au niveau de l'Ambassade
ou sur 15 personnes je suis la seule
dont on ne retrouve pas le passeport
comme on le dit en Afrique c'est ça on
appelle la sorcellerie
donc du coup tout le monde a commencé à
s'inquiéter
et vous savez ce que j'ai fait j'étais
sereine en fait j'ai juste fait une
seule chose
j'ai appelé mes pasteurs et je leur ai
dit voici la situation parce que en
toute chose il y a Dieu voici la
situation ils m'ont dit mais calme-toi à
midi 30 ils vont venir te remettre ton
passeport
donc je suis allé m'asseoir en faire
dans une salle c'est-à-dire tous mes
collègues m'ont laissé ils sont partis
je suis allé m'asseoir dans la salle
maintenant et puis je suis au même on me
donne l'ordinateur donc faut naviguer et
tout tout j'ai pris mon téléphone j'ai
commencé à prier
à 12h30 ils sont venus me chercher pour
me dire il y a une folo qu'on cherche
tout on doit lui remettre son passeport
je lui ai dit c'est moi
et je suis sortie de là
et quand je suis rentré chez moi
mon homme de Dieu m'a encore rappelé
puisqu'on avait une répétition pour ceux
qui savent pas je chante
donc nous allons encore la répétition et
la nuit avant de rentrer il m'a dit
quelque chose il m'a dit
vous allez chanter demain à 6h ne rentre
pas à la maison reste à l'église ici
parce que tu es dans un combat
actuellement
je dis d'accord et nous appeler à trois
et dit vous allez dormir dans mon bureau
prendre la clé je rentre à la maison
mais le matin je vous dis lorsque
j'étais en train de rendre ministère
mais ça n'allait pas je pouvais même pas
tenir debout et il a dit tiens bon parce
que je sens qu'il y a quelque chose qui
se passe là mais dès qu'on finit de
chanter j'en prends mon taxi même pas 10
minutes au niveau des accas je fais un
accident et je devais voyager le mardi
nous étions samedi
quand vous voyez en fait l'état du
véhicule
c'était pas en fait un accident dont
j'étais censée sortir parce que vraiment
il y a eu un choc mais je suis sorti à
part mon front qui était enflé et ce
jour là je partais faire mon
déménagement
mais je dis je regarde je regarde je dis
maintenant ce voyage là il faut que je
parte parce que moi je suis quelqu'un
qui n'abandonne pas en fait je
n'abandonne pas je dis toujours là la
seule chose où la seule situation dans
laquelle j'abandonne c'est lorsque c'est
dans une relation où je sais qu'on ne
m'aime plus là-bas je me cherche
mais à part cela les autres en France
parce que je suis une lionne et une
lionne n'abandonne pas
alors là
je me retrouve en fait à l'hôpital et
tout après je rentre à la maison
tranquille on dit non tu dois pas mettre
quelque chose sur mais je dis mon frère
je peux pas voyager comme ça ça fait
bizarre en fait et tout ça parmi mes
amis sont comptés qu'il y a d'autres que
je devais gérer sur place aujourd'hui
j'en parle il y avait les échappes pour
faire de la côte le gars ne décrochait
pas pourtant j'ai garantis à tout le
monde que j'ai déjà récupéré et le
monsieur est injoignable
élégant ma petite non c'est bon j'ai
récupéré mais pendant ce temps j'ai
appelé j'ai appelé j'ai appelé et encore
il y a il y a un grand frère qui m'a dit
non mais je vais prier pour toi Dieu m'a
dit de prier pour toi et tout pendant ce
temps j'avais mis un médicament sur le
front et il me dit non prends l'autre tu
laves le visage je voulais dormir donc
moi j'ai fait mon mes yeux se sont
enflés
donc là maintenant le fond on fait les
yeux sont enflés tu fais comment
et tu es là maintenant je me demande
mais attends ce voyage a finalement je
vais dans le pays d'autrui et puis tout
enflé sur moi
et pendant ce temps j'étais là j'ai
appelé j'ai appelé le celui qui qui
avait brodé le chapitre décrochait pas
mais je vous dis le matin le monsieur a
décroché à 5 heures du matin
et à 5h du matin mon frère est venu me
chercher à 6h pour pouvoir me conduire à
l'aéroport
la voiture dès que je mens dans le
véhicule la voiture refuse de démarrer
la voiture refuse de démarrer
et puis si c'est démarré seulement
c'était bien la portière refuse de
s'ouvrir
en fait je ne leur ai jamais expliqué
pourquoi est-ce que je suis arrivé en
retard aujourd'hui j'en parle en fait
parce que c'est drôle mais ce jour-là
c'était vraiment pas drôle donc du coup
je suis là mais je fais comment un
moment donné ma mère elle a pu me
regarde parce que quand les situations
commencent à arriver comme ça faut pas
s'approcher de voir donc j'étais là
maintenant et puis les autres appels
mais tu avais dit je suis en route mais
je suis passé d'abord récupérer
l'échappe et le temps d'arriver à
l'aéroport dès que j'arrive à l'aéroport
me dire le vol est fermé
mais là maintenant je suis là je
réfléchis tout le monde est dans l'avion
sauf moi je fais comment
qu'est-ce que je fais je suis là je
réfléchis l'ambassade essaie de trouver
une solution je m'appelle mon numéro
passe pas je suis là un moment donné
j'ai fondu en la mais j'ai commencé à
pleurer et tout le monde me regardait à
l'aéroport mais qu'est-ce qui ne va pas
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas je peux pas
expliquer à quelqu'un ce que je
ressentais en fait parce que un moment
donné je me suis dit mais là ça n'est de
trop mais c'est bon il faut que je vends
mais il faut que ça s'arrête là parce
que j'en peux plus
j'en peux plus mais vous savez
entre la résignation et la résilience
il y a une sorte de ligne en fait parce
que du côté de la résilience en fait il
y a il y a des personnes qui sont là qui
vous tendent la main pour pouvoir vous
aider à avancer mais lorsque vous
décidez en fait de vous résigner vous
êtes seul face à vous-même face à votre
destin et moi ce jour là j'ai vu en fait
14 personnes qui étaient prêtes pour moi
plus les membres de l'ambassade en fait
ça faisait près d'une vingtaine de
personnes et j'ai vu en fait ce que
c'est que la force de l'amour en fait ce
que c'est que le fait d'avoir des
personnes en fait qui sont prêtes pour
vous en fait à vous aider à avancer et
je suis tellement reconnaissante en fait
pour ces personnes parce que
je me dis en fait lorsque tu traverses
une situation que tu n'as personne en
fait à qui parler tu te perds en fait et
là tu te retrouves en fait au bout d'un
tunnel tu sais même pas ce que tu dois
faire est-ce que tu abandonnes ou est-ce
que en fait tu essaies de te surpasser
là tu es tu te retrouves en fait à ce
carrefour là
et c'est comme ça que je t'ai ce jour un
moment donné ma mère me dit mais bon tu
sais tu dois avoir un financement ici
les gars te disent non que tu vas signer
le document demain c'est pas bien tu vas
laisser voyage là tu vas venir prendre
l'argent là
donc un moment donné je suis à la
République j'ai réfléchi il a dit à ma
mère si cette somme là c'est pour moi ça
va attendre mon retour en fait parce que
ce voyage là il faut que je l'effectue
parce que je sais que ça aura un impact
en fait sur ma vie et sur la vie de
beaucoup de personnes si c'était pas
prévu que je fasse ce voyage je serai
pas arrivé jusque là
et là maintenant l'ambassade me rappelle
me dit non on te programme pour ce soir
mais il faut que tu ressortes pour aller
faire encore un autre test des tests
dont je ressors pour aller faire mon
test j'arrive à l'aéroport à 18h j'ai
dit cette fois-ci je rate pas mon vol
mais je vous assure
à 18h j'étais à l'aéroport à 19h je
tenais plus debout c'est comme en fait
ce type de sommeil qui te prend ou tu
sais que tu ne peux plus bouger tu sais
même plus je n'arrivais même plus à
regarder comme ça je n'arrivais même
plus
et il y a un ami qui m'a appelé
peu importe là où il est aujourd'hui si
monsieur je suis aussi reconnaissante et
il m'a dit tiens tu n'es pas comme ça
d'habitude parce que toi je te connais
tu dors pas avant 2h du matin parce que
je suis insomniaque en fait je dors pas
je dors maxi peut-être deux à trois
heures par jour
donc du coup il dit tu n'es pas dans ton
état normal il faut en fait
que tu que je réussisse en fait à te
garder éveillé parce que là à 19h tu as
sommeil c'est pas possible je vous
assure
les deux autres avec qui je devais
voyager le soir était déjà en train de
de de d'aller dans la salle
d'embarquement moi j'étais là j'ai même
pas entendu la lettre pourtant j'étais
dans l'aéroport
donc quand je suis monté ils ont dit ah
bah tu es arrivé j'ai dit oui oui
arrivons en Turquie mon porte-monnaie
disparaît
et j'étais là m'ont donné j'ai dit mais
non ça va pas se passer comme ça à faire
le gouvernement doit nous envoyer
l'argent là
c'est pas possible et puis toutes mes 4
sont dedans donc j'étais là j'ai
commencé à fouiller partout et puis
recette 30 minutes avant qu'on ne puisse
embarquer j'étais là je
fouille et puis je me disais mais
attends
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas je comprends pas
et puis ça je me suis adressée au grand
barbu je me suis adressée à Dieu
parce que quand ça arrive un certain
niveau là les amis ne peut plus rien
faire on a besoin d'une personne suprême
en fait et là j'ai dit il faut que je
retrouve ce portefeuille là
et j'arrive
vous savez il y a une sorte de petit
découragement qui est là parce que je
fouillé je n'ai pas retrouvé mais je
retourne quand même à la salle
d'embarquement et là on me dit madame
vous étiez pas tu me dis NON je cherche
à mon portefeuille on dit c'est de
quelle couleur je leur dis aujourd'hui
ça y est là tu dis d'accord on arrive
maintenant aux États-Unis
mais en fait vous vous demandez en fait
quel est le lien en fait en tout ce que
je raconte et puis le thème du jour
ce soir je suis en train de vous parler
de l'influence en fait de la résilience
sur la guérison de la violence sexuelle
si des personnes ne m'avaient pas tendu
en fait la main pour pouvoir m'aider en
fait à avancer je serai en train de me
morfondre aujourd'hui personne
n'entendrait parler de ma vie à Jocelyne
personne ne sera en fait qui je suis
aujourd'hui
avant-hier j'étais avec ma sœur et un
monsieur qui m'a vu il a dit ah c'est
vous qui êtes passé dans l'émission sur
TV5 Monde j'ai dit oui elle dit ah tu es
devenu célèbre maintenant
en fait il y avait ce petit sentiment de
fierté parce que je me dis
il faut en fait que je travaille jusqu'à
ce que je n'ai plus à me présenter
et je travaille dans l'ombre pour que
demain en fait je n'ai plus à me
présenter
et vous savez ce qui est déplorable en
fait dans tous cette histoire c'est que
quand vous êtes victime de ce que moi
j'ai vécu en fait
il y a le visage en fait que vous
montrez à l'extérieur qui est toujours
cette personne qui est souriante moi
chaque fois qu'on me voit d'ailleurs je
suis souriante
mais à l'intérieur quand tu rentres tu
es face à toi-même
tu es face à ton miroir et tu vois en
fait ta vie est triste tu te dis non ça
ne va pas tu te dis des personnes et
joyeuse mais tu te dis mais en fait il y
a et généralement c'est ce qui pousse
les gens au suicide
j'ai un ami qui a voulu se suicider
cette année s'est passé sur les réseaux
sociaux je suis sûr que beaucoup de
personnes l'ont vu
dès que j'ai appris je suis allée à son
chevet parce que la première fois que
j'ai changé avec lui je savais qu'il
voulait se suicider et j'ai essayé de
l'aider mais vous savez c'est la
résignation il fait comme si de rien
n'était jusqu'à ce qu'il passe en fait à
l'acte et je me suis sentie très mal
parce que je me suis dit j'aurais pu
faire quelque chose même s'il ne voulait
pas fallait que j'insiste en fait
alors pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle
de tout ceci ce soir
vous savez
j'aurais pu abandonner
mais j'ai décidé de me surpasser en fait
et
j'ai un pseudo que Sunshine tout le
monde m'appelle comme ça ce qui signifie
que le soleil brille je suis habillée en
blanc et jaune ce soir le blanc parce
que ça représente en fait la pureté pour
moi l'innocence en fait et le jaune
parce que en tant que coach en
développement personnel et aliments au
projet c'est une couleur que nous
utilisons beaucoup parce que ça
représente en fait la joie la gaieté
l'amitié et tout ce qui va avec
aujourd'hui j'ai beaucoup d'amis sur qui
je peux compter chaque fois que je suis
dans le besoin est-ce que vous amis
peuvent compter sur vous lorsqu'ils sont
dans le besoin c'est la question que
vous devez vous poser ce soir
combien de fois vous avez tondu la mer à
quelqu'un cette année combien de fois
vous avez pris votre téléphone pour
pouvoir appeler quelqu'un pour savoir
comment est-ce que cette personne allait
combien de fois vous avez essayé de
détecter en fait ce qui n'allait pas
chez quelqu'un souvent on a tendance à
dire non mais si il veut pas répondre
mais moi je le laisse comme ça mais non
moi chaque fois que je vois quelqu'un
qui allait être j'essaie d'approcher
cette personne pour savoir mais
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas dans sa vie et
généralement les gens ont l'art de se
confier à moi
peut-être que c'est
une qualité je dirais pas peut-être
c'est une qualité c'est un don seul Dieu
sait
le bilan en fait sur les cas de viol ne
sont pas n'est pas vraiment positif en
Côte d'Ivoire
vous savez
environ
1000 femmes
sans victimes de violence sexuelles en
Côte d'Ivoire
chaque année
et c'est vraiment triste de pouvoir
constater cela parce que
on a l'impression en fait que
selon ce que les gens pensent elles ont
provoqué selon vous qu'est-ce que nous
avons de trois ans
a pu bien de montrer afin de pouvoir
provoquer quelqu'un quelque chose sur
une personne peut-être qui a 60 ans rien
du tout
rien du tout
souvent lorsque vous empruntez en fait
ce chemin là vous vous dites non mais
attends je suis déjà arrivé tu te dis
que tu as tu as tu as tué guéri en fait
mais en réalité tu ne l'es pas moi
jusqu'en 2021 je pensais que j'étais
guéri de cela jusqu'à ce que je
rencontre en fait mon menton monsieur
Goro Adama et que je change avec le lors
d'une session et que je sache que
maintenant j'étais pas encore guéri et
pendant cette année j'ai décidé de
briser le tableau et j'ai exposé en fait
mon histoire sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup m'ont connu en fait grâce à
cela
alors je disais que mille femmes sont
victimes de violences sexuelles chaque
année
pratiquement en Côte d'Ivoire
et moi j'ai décidé moi j'ai choisi
d'être en fait cette oreille là à qui
elle pourront se confier d'être cette
voix
qui leur permettra en fait de pouvoir
arriver à la résilience
afin de pouvoir influencer leur guérison
et vous
que feriez-vous aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
aider en fait quelqu'un
à pouvoir
emprunter ce chemin de la résilience là
j'aimerais qu'on quittons ici ce soir
que vous vous posez cette question et
qu'avant la fin de cette année 2023 que
vous soyez en fait un influenceur ou une
influenceuse pour quelqu'un autour de
vous un influenceur c'est parce que
quelqu'un qui a 1000 abonnés sur les
réseaux sociaux même si vous réussissez
en fait à impacter la vie d'une seule
personne vous êtes un influenceur
et vous influencer des personnes
positivement
alors tout comme moi je vous invite en
fait à influencer votre monde et surtout
à aider les femmes et les hommes qui
sont victimes de violences sexuelles
parce que oui les hommes sont violents
sont victimes aussi de violences
sexuelles et j'en ai rencontré il y a
pas longtemps
lorsque vous laissez vos nounours à la
maison avec vos enfants elles abusent en
fait de vos petits garçons j'ai
rencontré un jeune étudiant il y a pas
longtemps il m'a raconté son histoire
mais les hommes en fait en haut d'en
parler les gens auront d'en parler
pourquoi parce que chacun a peur d'être
jugé en fait
alors lorsque vous quittez cette salle
ce soir
ne soyez pas ces personnes à qui jugent
mais soyez ces personnes à qui tendent
la main et qui aident d'autres personnes
en fait à pouvoir se tenir debout et
participer aussi à des programmes en
fait des changes comme moi ce soir je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]